Lanthanum is the first element in a series
called the ‘rare earths’. They
are not terribly rare but never-the-less they
are called rare earths and
they all have rather similar names so there
is quite an amusing little
rhyme, mnemonic, that people learn to remember
the names which at
the first two letters of each word tell you
this chemical symbol the
elements so this goes ‘Language Centres
Praise Ned’s Promise of Small
European Garden Tubs. Dinosaurs Hobble Erotically
Thrumming Yellow
Lutes’, which takes us from lanthanum all
the way to lutetium.
Lanthanum is the largest of the lanthanides.
It’s a prototype for the
lanthanide series and because it is the largest
it is the most reactive. It’s
a strange metal in that you can actually cut
it with a knife. So it’s not
actually that hard.
I haven’t worked much with lanthanum but
one of my students or a
Russian visitor did some rather interesting
experiments with making a
compound of lanthanum and copper, so-called
lanthanum cuprate, which
is quite an interesting catalyst.
Lanthanum’s got quite a few technological
uses. It’s used in, of all things,
lighting in Hollywood studios. Lanthanum can
also be used in hydrogen
storage though obviously the hydrogen economy
is becoming a very
important issue with the energy crisis and
so on and so forth; and it’s, in
certain circumstances, it’s very effective
as what we called a hydrogen
sponge so it can suck up all of the hydrogen
and then hopefully you
could use it as a fuel source. But because
it’s quite heavy it might not be
actually that useful in the end, but it’s
good to know that it can do that.